monsieur clar bonjour merci à d'être
avec nous en direct de one je le
rappelle alors one inde est confiné mais
toujours à se contrôler oui tout à fait
c'est un sentiment de liberté
aujourd'hui je viens d'aller faire des
courses dans un supermarché habituel
pour la première fois depuis depuis plus
de deux mois mais c'est une un sentiment
partagé par ce que il y a cette
procédure de déconfinement qui est très
progressive et donc ceci est encadré par
une une contrôles sanitaires extrêmement
strictes et aujourd'hui il ya encore des
débours année qui sont confinés dans
leur résidence parce qu'elle veut il y a
eu des cas dépistés ces derniers jours
et actuellement les chinois des pistes
surtout des sujets qui présente le virus
et qui sont asymptomatiques
alors vous parlez de déconfinement
progressif qu'est ce qui est ouvert
qu'est ce qui reste fermé caloy de
sortir de chez soi
alors en fait depuis hier tout est
ouvert et notamment l'aéroport
international les magasins sont tous
ouverts
maintenant il ya cette hausse et sus de
déconfinement avec un certificat de
bonne santé sous la trame d'informatiser
sous la forme d'un qr codes que chaque
chinois a sur son smartphone est donc en
fonction de ce certificat de santé oms
on peut on ne peut pas sortir de sa
résidence
donc quand certains our années sont
encore confiné actuellement dans
l'horreur dans leur résidence
un certificat de santé sur quelle base
ça veut dire que tous les one et ont été
dépistés alors ça veut dire soit vous
avez subi une quarantaine suffisamment
longue et strictes puisque vous savez
que les chinois ont appliqué une
quarantaine un confinement strict faut
quelqu'un vous avez dépassé la période
d'incubation est donc vous êtes négatif
soit vous avez été malade et puis vous
avez un test qui prouve que vous avez
des anticorps c'est ce qu'on appelle une
sérologie
hélas ce moment là vous avez un
certificat de santé qui passent au vert
et que vous permet de tanner dans
l'espace dans l'espace public sur vous
avez été un sujet contact c'est à ce
moment là il faut à nouveau avoir une
cale de confinement de quarantaine
au moins 14 jours sans symptômes pour
pouvoir à nouveau rentrer dans l'espace
public alors mais c'est quand vous êtes
médecin wannehain ville qui semble en
tout cas se remettre doucement nous on
est en plein dedans dans certains pays
européens le pic est même pas passé et
quels conseils donneriez-vous aux
populations qui se pose beaucoup de
questions masque ou pas masquer
chloroquine ou pas chloroquine doigts
pour rester confiné quand serons-nous
des confiné quels conseils l'écouté nous
avons ici un modèle grandeur nature qui
est le modèle chinois
à partir du moment où les chinois ont
pris des mesures et une méthode
extrêmement enfin efficace
on va dire c'est à dire le 17 février il
aura fallu cinquante deux jours à l'eau
à la région du groupe hey à la ville de
vaughan soit 60 millions de personnes
pourraient naître des confiné et
retrouver une activité économique donc à
ce jour il n'ya que ce modèle là
puisqu'on en est à peu près au stade où
était la chine au départ lorsqu'elle
encaisser cette nouvelle cette nouvelle
épidémie on en est au même stade en
france donc on doit appliquer des
méthodes identiques pour arriver à un
résultat aussi rapide puisque je vous
rappelle que le but c'est quand même
d'arriver à retrouver une vie économique
normale le plus rapidement possible bien
entendu en ayant le moins de pertes le
moins de décès possibles selon vous le
confinement en france n'est pas assez
stricte comparé à celui qui a été
appliquée en chine oui tout à fait le
confinement en france n'arrête pas la
propagation du virus il ya trop de
circulation de personnes donc le virus
continue à circuler sur le territoire
national français à l'heure actuelle les
chinois s'en sont rendus compte vers la
mi février puisque ça faisait trois
semaines qu'ils avaient ce mode de
confinement où vous pouvez quand même
sortir de chez soi et ils se sont rendu
compte que ça ne contenait pas
l'épidémie et qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures plus efficaces
alors vous avez emmanuel macron en ligne
qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit si ce
n'est pas confidentiel
alors je lui ai raconté alors en fait
depuis la mi mars lorsque j'ai vu que
les choses se dégrader en dans le nord
de l'italie puis ensuite en espagne et
est chez nous en france
je me suis évertué à alerter les
français sur la dangerosité de cette
cette épidémie et la nécessité de
prendre des mesures
le plus rapidement possible identique à
celle qu'avait pris les chinois de façon
à ne pas perdre son temps qu'à limiter
au maximum le choc sanitaire la
surmortalité et les conséquences
économiques désastreuses pour nos
concitoyens filet merci d'avoir été avec
moi merci pour ces concerts il rappelle
que vous êtes médecin chef à la clinique
internationale de houra nom chinois wang
est en train d'être des confiné en tout
cas progressivement merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous